2年間縛りから生活を何でもやり続けてる
の本当にすごいありがとう
今年も
発表させていただきますこんにちははじめ
しゃちょーですーげー2022年になり
ました
[音楽]
これだけストを込め禁止辛い一年間でした
辛いといってもパンとか面とかラーメン
パサーが膨れたんでにどうしても米が食べ
たいっていう時期はあったんですけどそこ
られればで行けたんで大丈夫なんですけど
も毎年コーデになっております肇社長の1
年間
まるまる禁止まるまる縛り生活っていうの
をあのずっとやらせていただいているん
ですけれども歴史が結構長くてちょっと見
ていきましょうかおお
2016年から始まってるみたいですね
以前じろぐねーはもうお菓子食べませんお
菓子を禁止した1年2017年もう
ラーメン食べませんラーメン地生活
2018年でどうもお肉を食べません肉
禁止生活チェーン2級ね氏福禁止生活1年
がスーツ縛り生活で逃げ20年1年間腹筋
縛り生活そして2021年を込め禁止生活
が無事終え今2022年に至るという感じ
でございますもうねあの正直
きつい正直きついんですよあの角撮影がせ
ていただきますとなんかハードルが
どんどん上がっていって者ってもうあの
腹筋一日腹筋300系だからちょっと結構
もう辛いというかんこれ以上やったら自分
はユーチューバーではなく職業が1年間
縛り職人みたいなチャットで今回の1年間
の縛りもですね結構悩みはいろんなことを
考えました禁止生活を決める上に置いて
あの難しいのが内容によってはすごい周り
に迷惑をかけたりお仕事にすごい影響が出
たり自分の私生活がハチャメチャになっ
たり自分だけの被害だったらいいんです
けども周りの人までに迷惑をかけることに
多くてです2020人の縛りも相当考え
ましたいろんな掲示生がいろんな縛り警察
いろんな縛り生活が結構 no なに出て
きていろいろイメージしてみたんですよ
[音楽]
か見てみてうんん
降っハ
r
[笑い]
[音楽]
はぁおはようございましょう
omap ないからー
ああああああ
穴よろしくなんだ
創刊
whいきたいなぁいいなぁ
picture
ん
[音楽]
なんかメッセやコメしてもうちょいマシだ
よな音ね jal から ok さ等
チャオはなんかもしれんなこれ家堂島って
わけ
おっ
tan
[音楽]
後もうちょっと待ってるッ
はぁ
ああ
もうどん
立派でも充実充実もう編集撮影ですねこれ
じゃないかぁああ
テレキャスヒョンソンとよっしゃジャスト
つ
これら a でおいいかなはいいかがだっ
たでしょうか結構いろいろを思いついた
いるんですよね想像も出来てて意外と
イケるんじゃないかなと思ったのが1年間
外出禁止生活1年ぶり2度開けてみる空の
青さ想像を超える美しさだと思うんですよ
則本決して月とかも東京行く何に静岡から
だと往復で1か月かかりそうですなんか
もうねかもすごいいろいろ考えたんです
けども私
たどり着きました
発表いたします私
肇社長は
2022年
ちーせ
近時成果としまう
はい禁止禁止生活禁止を禁止します
きませんでもその名の通りなんですけども
今年は禁止しません
はいで g a のみだとりあえずで線
2016年から始まってる禁止生活
2022年でしょもう6年もやってるわけ
ですよ何かを禁止する生活で7年目になる
とハードルもどんどん上がっていくやり
たい金砂たくさんですけどももちろん自分
の仕事にも支障が出たり周りの1人の被害
も甚大なものになっていくとこれ果たして
いつまで続けるんだろうって思った時に私
去年年末にチャンネル登録者数1000万
人おかげさまで行ったんですよここかなと
ここかなと思いました帰る時はもう禁止
啓発
なれたんですよ正直6年間いろんなものを
禁止したらなんか民体力というか我慢
できる時間はかなり人以上に付いたと思う
んですよ謹慎生活6年間やってきて得
られるものを持つのたくさんありました
失脚に失ったもの結構あったんですよそれ
何か当たり前の生活でそうなんですあの逆
に取れ6年間普通の生活してなくて普通
ってなんだろう
普通ってなんだろうみたいな感じになっ
ちゃってなんかもう忍耐力もついた水沢に
失ったものそういうのもそうですし今年は
弾み雪を変わりたいなという年にしたいと
思っておりません2022年禁止する行為
ということをしないことが自分への一番の
今の自分への一番手縛り行為禁止行為だと
思ってて肇社長チャンネル1000万人
入ったということで今年はちょっと
いろいろ変えていきたいなと思っており
まして禁止生活に頼らずそうした金氏を1
年間禁止させていただきます
フリーダムです6年ぶりに梅雨になりまし
た逆にそういう禁止とか縛りがないことに
よってなら今まで以上に気持ちよくという
か自由に今年は youtube の発動
とかお仕事に専念できるかなと思っている
所存でございます6年間の縛り欽一生活で
ある程度の忍耐力とか我慢する力ついた
この力を持ったままで自由にというか1回
全てない状態で自由に活動してみたいなと
思って今年1年はそういう年にしたいと
思いますそうそうするんですよ本当にこれ
でいいのかっていう何かで死んだかある
意味だかそのたびみたいな存在だと思って
て禁止っていうものがその禁止っていう
ものがあるからなそれにすがって生きて
たっていうのが6点が続いてたんでなんか
こう心とっかりあのが開いたような感覚に
襲われてるんですけどもその空いた穴を
ライター何をし寿司をして押しずしはし
ないですけどそのアイターなのよゆーよ
ゆーでもっと活動の幅を広げたりいろんな
事をしたり何か楽しいことできたらいいな
と思っておりますあのなので今年のはじめ
しゃちょー楽しいでちょっといろいろ今
までの
当たり前だってはじめ社長から新しいはず
3冊んでねーなーと思ってて今回は禁止を
禁止させていただきました結構自分の中で
も悔しいというかはここで終わっちゃうん
だみたいな感じんですけど変化ってそう
いうものだと思うんですよ何かを犠牲にし
ないと人は変わりませんという感じで今年
はいきたいとおもいますでねー今年
ちょっと目標にしたいことがあるんです
けども視聴者さんとのコミュニケーション
の機会を増やしたいっていうのが住んで
今年の動画があるならたまにあるんです
けども twitter のリップを最初
に絶対答えるとかやってたんですけど今年
は中中部の保免と卵のコメント1個必ず
多くニングで変身してから動画を始めたい
と思いますのでみなさんぜひ
youtube の方コメントとかを待つ
しております村でですねちょっと皆さんの
意見を取り入れたいもう自分のしたいこと
をやり尽くしで1戦何年までたどり着き
ましたこの先肇社長がもっと成長するには
どうしたらいいんだろうと思った時自分の
子たいこととか変態ことを持つがなんです
けどもみんながしてほしいことから見たい
こととかもどんどんやっていくべきかなと
思いましてえっと始めちゃってイースター
グラムのは雁塔あるんですけどもここ8 d
m 開放しておりますという狭い家
たくさんメッセージクールで全部見れない
んですけどもなるべく見て暇があったら
改札してるんですけどをめっちゃといいや
んと思ったら動画にするかも知れませんの
でぜひ皆さん
[音楽]
寝てくださいネタゲーとかじゃないんです
よたくさんありたことありますけども自分
のしたいこと+皆さんのしたいことを叶え
ていくのがまあ俺の使命だと思ってるんで
分野の声に行ってほしいとかったらのネタ
提供是非お待ちしておりますインサーの
ゲーム開放していますので帰ってこなくて
もお金ないでねそういう感じでちょっとね
今年1年は皆さんとも切る縮めつつかつ
自由に1000万人入ってなんか肩の荷が
降りましたといろいろ今まですよってな
ものバットしてに神にーずにねちょっと
また変わったはじめシャツを来たし見せれ
ばいいなと思っております何警視にするん
だろうって楽しみにしてた方ごめんなさい
今年はそういうちょっと変化の年にしたい
んだと呼んで今年も始者等よろしくお願い
ますじゃじゃーん
[音楽]
ブーフ
のおっ
ん
ben